after months of delay chad's national
dialogue has begun in the capital in
germany bringing together more than 50
rebel and opposition groups among others
it aims to end years of conflict and
instability
today we find ourselves as a decisive
turning point in the history of our
country because in a few moments we're
going to lay the first milestones in the
refoundation of our republic
the notre republic
the talks follow a peace agreement
signed between the governing military
council and rebel groups last week in
doha it paved the way for the rebels to
return to chad and join the discussions
among the issues to be addressed are a
new constitution governance and a
timeline for national elections
delegates will form committees to tackle
the various issues despite the large
number of participants there are a few
but crucial groups missing it's prompted
concerns that even if the dialogue
brings peace it may not last
and stability is needed half of chad's
13 million people live in poverty and
hundreds of thousands have been
displaced by conflict the front for
change and concord one of two main rebel
groups not taking part in the talks says
more needs to be done for the process to
work
we did request
equal representation of the different
opposition and government at the
national dialogue they refused to give
to access to this request
and also they refused to release our
prisoner as soon as we signed the
agreement
and also they did not give enough
security guarantees so these are some
reason we do why we refuse to sign the
agreement
other groups have also boycotted the
talks including the civil society group
wakitama which has repeatedly called for
anti-government protests
utter which mediated the peace agreement
that led to these talks says it will
work to bring in those who are yet to
join
we are now working on facilitating
issues we will not abandon them until
the reconciliation is complete we've
invited the groups that have not signed
the peace agreement to join and we urge
them to join the doors open for them to
be part of the process
a process that is scheduled to last for
three weeks and one that many here hope
will bring a new chapter for chad free
of conflict and political turmoil hebel
morgan al jazeera jamaina